so i'm pleased to introduce our guest
john kerry our nation's first special
presidential envoy for climate
and the first principle to sit on the
national security council dedicated
to climate change i think you know prior
to his current service secretary kerry
was the carnegie endowment for
international pieces first ever visiting
distinguished statesman
he was our country's top diplomat for
four years as the 68th
united states secretary of state he's a
decorated combat veteran and served 25
years in the u.s senate
and as many of you know secretary kerry
is a distinguished fellow at yale in the
jackson institute and a member of the
yale college class
of 1966. so secretary kerry thank you
for joining us today and we've gathered
a lot of questions for you so i want to
jump right in
uh i know you'll be representing uh the
united states at the 2021
uh united nations climate change
conference
at the end of the year and we'd be
interested in hearing what your goals
are for
for that event well peter first of all
it's great to be with yale climate day
and michael thank you and peter thank
you for the invitation to be with you
um we are woefully behind
where we ought to be on an international
basis
in paris we all agreed to keep the
earth's temperature increase
well below 2 degrees and if possible at
1.5 degrees centigrade
and the truth is that uh we're far from
that uh
we knew in paris that even if everybody
did what they were gonna do we'd still
rise in temperature to about 3.7 degrees
and because we're not doing everything
people said they would do
we're actually hitting four degrees or
more so it's quite
fundamentally catastrophic on the upside
we have the ability to avoid the worst
consequences of climate we really can do
this
but the next 10 years are absolutely
critical so the goal
at glasgow is to bring global ambition
way up we had a summit in the white
house uh
last month that president biden hosted
that summit resulted in about 55
of global gdp being committed
to keep to the 1.5 degrees and that
includes japan
canada the united states the uk europe
etc
but we're now working with the other 45
that's the diplomacy of the next six
months
how do we bring everybody else on board
to change their national determined
contribution
ndc as it's called raise their ambition
so that we lay out a plan literally a
road map
for 10 years to get to 2030
with preserving 1.5 degrees and then
building on the plans to go to 2050 net
zero
which more and more people are now
adopting the problem is peter we don't
want to be stuck
with a whole bunch of wow we're for 2050
debt zero that's our deal because it
doesn't get us there
you've got to get people to buy into the
next 10 years
that's the goal of glasgow that and
finance
and then what's called the rule book we
need to kind of close out the rules by
which we're going to
implement this over the next years
you know you're mentioning uh uh the
setting of goals
and uh the long-term orientation that
that
many have when we need a we need a
decade uh
this decade orientation but it's true
that
uh you know with your help many
institutions
many uh uh companies financial companies
uh
others uh universities as well
have made pledges to reduce emissions
and
uh have set goals for themselves how can
we be sure
uh how can we have confidence that there
are concrete paths toward meeting these
goals and
that these institutions actually put
them in place
rather than just put the goal on a sign
and hope for the best
well that's that's partly the rule book
that we i just talked about which is
going to require
uh you know updated data
but secondly we now have available to us
peter
an extraordinary array of digital
space-based
and other means of tracking what people
are doing
al gore has worked on the development of
thing called trace
along with climate activists and others
it's creating an ability to be able to
have real-time
readout on exactly what the footprint of
a global company is or of an institution
i mean you could from space focus in on
yale and you can read out
exactly what yale's missions are at that
point in time and extrapolate
so that you know public shaming public
accountability is going to be one of the
things
as people buy into a global endeavor uh
we're not able
to have force of law for a number of
different reasons
so this really does rely on leveraging
people but here's the other big thing
that is happening
and it's really exciting private capital
there is no government in the world that
has enough money to be able to close the
finance
gap that the un has identified there's a
one to two trillion dollar per year
finance gap
just for the energy sector in the
transition we need to make in the next
30 years
so how do you do this well we've gone to
individual finance institutions we've
got six of the largest banks in america
they've created a floor of a commitment
over the next 10 years that will put
about uh 4.16 trillion dollars
to use for climate investment during
that period of time
and that's without factoring in a bunch
of asset managers
and you take an entity like blackrock
blackrock is
probably going to put another trillion
in maybe two over the course
10 years who knows but if you start
adding this
up uh the accrued amount of investment
is going to be unlike anything we've
ever seen and people are already moving
there
look at look at tesla the value of tesla
is more than
uh more than exxon mobil bp chevron put
together
and and all it does is make electric
cars oh it does i mean it's not
minimalist
but uh the the race now to
to zero emissions vehicles is intense
and you've got major automobile
companies gm says they're going to have
no more internal combustion engines
after 2035.
ford is moving in the same direction
european
uh car maker is moving in the same
direction so the momentum of the
marketplace
is also going to provide a level of
impetus
as well as accountability in my judgment
and uh
people are going to demand this this
this is taken on
thanks to young people sort of speaking
out and
and screaming about the future i think
finally
people are saying wait a minute there's
actually money to be made in this
enterprise
we build out the grid of america we
build cars there's more work
fat one of the fastest growing jobs in
america is
wind turbine technician third fastest
growing job in america solar
panel installer and and so there can be
a lot of changes in our economy that
come from this
i think it's the biggest transformation
theater since the industrial revolution
bigger by far than the technology
revolution of the 1990s in computer desk
computers and
mobile phones and so forth this is going
to be gigantic
and i think the marketplace realizes it
and every board room in america
is now grappling with esg considerations
environment
social and governance and you also have
the
sustainable development goals of the
united nations that are
hanging over people so you know we may
finally see a moment of global
responsibility but as i said
45 percent has still not signed up
and we've got to move those countries
and they're big
china india russia
some of the biggest emitters on the
planet 20 countries
are the equivalent of about 75 percent
of all emissions
we are going to continue to work with
those 20 countries
you uh you were mentioning young people
in your
answer that question and of course we're
a university and we have many students
who are watching this symposium today
and participating in climate day
and i'd be interested in your thoughts
about what students what younger people
can can do to influence climate policy
and in particular uh uh you know what
are the skills
that you need if you really want to be
someone who
works on the policy front and maybe has
a career like yours
well i think the skill set peter is the
same as
skill sets and other discipline i mean
you know
if you're a decent student in whatever
it is you do
if you want to focus on climate it's
there to be focused on and we need you
desperately the fact is that
i mean yale's doing a great job in the
various schools of
instilling a lot of interest in people i
was privileged in my
fellows and and in my seminar to have
people who were just super motivated and
focused
uh a couple of whom i bumped into down
here in washington you know one's
working in the white house one's for the
state department i mean
it happens very quickly so um
the fact is that young people
historically and i say this with some
measure of pride
because in the 1960s a lot of us became
involved in the civil rights movement of
64 65
and the environment movement the women's
movement the peace movement the war in
vietnam
and the first thing i did i remember was
marching in and not just marching but
organizing earth day
in massachusetts in new england back in
1970
that that mobilization of
voters is ultimately what happened
was a moment of accountability based on
environment
and immediately the congress passed the
clean air act safe drinking water marine
mammal protection coastal zone
management
endangered species and we created the
environmental protection agency of our
country
that came out of young people student
activism
people going out and holding the system
accountable to a large measure that's
happened already
uh with respect i think 20 i think 2020
is the first election since 1970 in
which
environment was in fact a voting issue
and president biden
seized on it had a major proposal in the
context of the campaign he's
implementing it now
rejoining paris leaning on the summit
beginning
getting a 50 to 52 target to reduce in
america
i think young folks are to look at that
and say gosh you know we really played a
role in helping to make that happen but
boy are we not finished
this transition is going to be a fight
and we need everybody involved in this
fight
you know yale has such a long history of
educating
uh young people for service to
state and community and uh
i of course hope that will continue we
try to give students as many
opportunities we can to learn those
skills and and
be inspired by people like you and
participate
in what's going on in washington or
for that matter in hartford or new haven
um
speaking of politics uh what uh you know
we're
we we have such highly uh
polarized political debate in this
country now and uh
you know climb even climate change i say
even climate years climate change
is highly politicized uh as well
and yet it's going to really take a
united effort it would seem
uh to develop a solutions
and to address the address the crisis in
just the ways that you suggest what
what can we do and is there a role for
universities
in addition to our convening function uh
to uh help bridge these political
divides and get people on the same page
and
not make this yet another area where
a big swath of the country simply um is
not interested in engaging
well peter that's boy that's the big uh
that's the big challenge to the country
and there's the big question
um to some measure yale's motto
addresses that lux at veritas
we need truth we don't have a baseline
for truth
in our in our system right now uh
people actually have the ability and
have been
creating their own facts uh
creating their own reality look at
what's happening with uh president trump
i mean i don't want to politicize this
but what's happening in this context of
of us of the big lie and the big steel
uh if that's the motivation of the major
party in our country we really have a
problem in trying to
get things done in a bipartisan fashion
and
the only thing i can really honestly
think of to say to people
is there's no automatic pilot
for democracy you you don't just cruise
along you can't cruise along
you have to fight for what is the truth
you have to fight for it now that's been
happening
and you know the demonstrations after
george floyd
the the the police reform initiative now
other kinds of things are emanating out
of this
struggle and the victory of uh president
biden
is in fact a reflection of that of a
large part of that battle he
ran on restoring the soul of our country
and and wanting to restore
some norms not every norm not everything
should be normal in the same way all the
time
changes change and we embrace it but it
can't be
reckless autocratic
authoritarian anti-democratic change
in the united states of america that
people fall into
because they feel powerless or weak or
frustrated by what is
not happening we have to fight for that
very very hard
and given what's happening in these laws
being passed around the country
in many many legislatures that are going
to make it harder for people to vote
i think that is a recipe for the
potential of real implosion of violence
i mean because what it's trying to do is
legitimize the steel
actually have a steel create the the
predicate for it
and and that is going to require us to
uh also fight back
so you know this generation of yale
students is graduating at a moment where
we're not sending you know a lot of
troops off to another country to die
and that's the cause of action but what
ought to be the cause of action is their
freedom
and liberty and the baseline of truth
by which we can actually function as a
democracy because without it you don't
and you can't and you won't
certainly agree the um i know we don't
have a lot of time but let me bring it
back to yell
for just a moment um as you know we have
announced a
planetary solutions campus-wide project
uh that supports interdisciplinary
multidisciplinary research
uh on all things relevant to climate
change
uh and its consequences uh we
engage in campus behaviors to try to
change um
our our own um uh make ourselves
accountable for the cost of carbon we
emit
and uh be a model and
we recently announced some new
guidelines by which we're going to
evaluate holdings in our endowment
where fossil fuel production extraction
is
is concerned very recently we
received a very large gift from
fedex to support research
uh as part of this uh planetary
solutions project to support research
on natural methods of carbon capture
um and i'd be interested if you have
if if there are areas of research that
you think
why isn't anybody studying this where
what could gail
be focusing its attention on through our
planetary solutions project that you
think is an
understudied aspect of climate change or
it's uh remediation
uh that we we should seriously try to
organize
ourselves around direct air capture
yeah i mean if we can figure out how to
suck this stuff out of the atmosphere
and put it to use
we're in we're in the cat bird seat uh
two to three weeks of storage that's
katie bar the door
uh that's uh you just that's it we've
solved the problem
and um i think uh
uh i mean i think those are the biggest
obviously a lot of people are chasing
green hydrogen now
uh there's a lot of uh global endeavor
for that i think it's going to be one of
the fuels of the future without any
question
but the the challenge for us peter
is can we move fast enough
not will we move ultimately we're going
to get there and a certain percentage of
the population of the planet
will kind of you know learn how they'll
adapt and things will happen and we'll
waste a lot of money doing things we
never should have have to do
to survive as a species but a lot of
people won't
there will be a massive dislocation of
human beings with major food disruption
and other challenges so the issue here
is speeding everything up
if we can find ways to speed it up
we've got a much better chance of
arresting the melting of greenland
and the west antarctic ice sheet and the
other
major disruptions that are coming uh
at an alarming pace right now um and so
that's what i'd say i mean
you know bill gates in his book uh cites
that we need the one of three miracles
the miracle of storage the miracle of
fusion or the miracle of fishing
uh and he's pursuing the fission with a
next generation model nuclear reactor
uh which has a lot of promise but
the fact is that the scientists tell me
that about 50
of the emissions we need to get
to reach net zero are going to come from
technologies we don't have today
so it's sort of open season i mean i
think yale
well advised i think that's great money
that fedex is is invested
that is the great endeavor is to chase
any number of those
possibilities recognizing you know there
are a lot of people in certain sectors
you may want to isolate
one or two you know particular
avenues that is not quite as a path as
trod
and so well tried and come up with
something but those are the biggies
uh and and methane anybody who can find
a way you know we got a
we had a serious methane challenge
because the
melting of the permafrost and the
melting of the tundra
and and the and the massive exposure of
30 and 40 000 year frozen land
to a thawing is emitting massive amount
of heretofore
contained methane and methane is
you know 20 to 80 times more damaging
more destructive than co2
and it's now coming out in amounts that
are truly alarming
which will also exacerbate the gas
debate
because gas is 87.7 percent methane
and it leaks it leaks far more in other
countries than here but we're at about a
5
leakage and you add to that the untapped
unplugged wells and mines
from which methane is escaping one of
president biden's priorities in the in
the infrastructure bill
is the capping of those mines and those
wells
so those are the challenges and um
i think those are sort of the
centerpiece challenges
well senator kerry uh secretary kerry we
appreciate you
giving us time today and i want to allow
you to have the final word but
just to make sure that there's time to
express a little gratitude i want to
thank you for
kicking kicking off climate day for us
and uh we miss you on campus
it was great uh uh when you could be
with us uh more regularly and at
some point we look forward to welcoming
you back uh
uh in a more regularized way in the
meantime it is great to see you through
zoom and we
we do appreciate you spending some time
uh
with us any final words any final words
for our uh students
well first of all thank you peter to you
and thank you
thanks to yale for doing the climate day
um my my uh on a
note of optimism which we ought to end
on is
this is so doable that's what's so
frustrating about it
we know that we can move to massive
level of read
of renewable usage and then you just
need to balance sort of 10 or 15 percent
of your energy needs
batteries are now reaching a four hour
uh
length of time for utility scale
batteries
and there are communities on the planet
that are
at decarbonized status there are about
four or five of them
and and more coming so
we we can accelerate this and and i see
just fantastic opportunity to to
to make america fairer to deal with
environmental injustice that has
characterized a lot of the build-out
and development of the last 40-50 years
uh you know we we we can
we can uh i think
create millions not i think all of the
job
you know analyses for the long-term
future show
that there are far far more
uh jobs to be created in by going whole
hog into this arena of cleaning up
the planet uh and and uh building out
the new systems that will modernize our
nations lengthen our lives and
increase the quality of life make us
more secure
all of those things and every economic
analysis shows
it's far far more expensive to not
tackle this than it is to tackle it and
we're already seeing that we spent 265
billion dollars just cleaning up after
three storms a couple years ago
you know irma harvey and maria we we can
do better than this
and in the doing better we will make our
society stronger
more resilient uh fairer uh
and more prosperous and and healthier
and
and so i'm excited about the prospects i
really think this is worth the fight
well thank you uh thank you for those
encouraging optimistic uh
words uh um we certainly have a big
challenge ahead of us
as a university and as a country uh i
want to thank you for joining us
once again secretary kerry and i want to
welcome everybody to uh climate day
and uh uh very much hope
uh that it will be a stimulating day for
everybody participating with us today
thank you so much for being with us